why does he have to bring out his
receipts like that right exactly why
right and even if let's say eve listen
people already know
i do not like trump right but why do i
have to hate somebody because they like
him
right he gives a [ __ ] right like
whatever he's doing
obviously speaks to them on some kind of
[ __ ] level yeah right right like i
disagree with you but i'm not going to
go out of my way to [ __ ]
just trash you about it yeah right i'm
not going to hate you as a human
being that's the problem like you put
somebody on the map
about all this [ __ ] these you you say
he's doing all these things
but it's not true there's no proof of
this and then people are still smearing
him to this day about this happened a
year ago
i guess from my my recent research and
this is his
in five four three two one
yeah smash what does he call what does
he call a [ __ ] dick and a play man
you can't [ __ ]
start off like that jingly jing queen
jiggly what does he call a [ __ ] trump
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast i hope you guys are doing
very well this podcast is about anything
and everything sometimes we make you
think other times we make you wonder why
you
even started listening to this podcast
yes 100
we got patrick t dot riley come on baby
former 150 pound champ
after his retirement this spreads out
over tupac
yup he's uh he's retired now they're
tired one and done baby that's right
that 150 pound belt the comedy belt
giggling his way all the way to a [ __ ]
bam
and then we have nick the ear the coach
of the year apparently
over trevor whitman because
finally in the win column as well bang
bang bang boom
[ __ ] broke the street was that your
second fighter like second fight
or no you've you've coached heinrich too
yeah we've got but it's like it's been a
drought
shout out to heinrich i love you but
low-key it's been a drop
and then when alex fought we lost that
one too yeah
boy it's been it's been real dry let me
disappoint you in my fight
i got you both getting knocked out first
round don't care hands down
chin up yeah but we gotta talks about
first of all the borat movie because
that was like the hugest [ __ ] craze
of all time yeah right because borat's
out here trying to
expose america for what it is dude
what is his sasha baron cohen is his
actual name yeah yeah yeah
did you see uh when he did there's a
really funny probably the best bit to me
was not the rudy giuliani thing because
people kind of like pumped it up and
then when i saw it i was like oh that's
it i expected him to do that but uh it
was when he did this he does the song
called the wuhan flu oh that [ __ ] was
nuts and uh he's talking about like
i guess he has a line in the song about
like the nazis or something and then
some
i think i don't even know what state
they were in do you know i have no idea
they were
some countries yeah they yeah they were
they were very uh pro-trump or whatever
but it's probably you know who knows who
knows what these people are whatever it
doesn't matter
but he talks about like nazis or
something like that in the song and then
there's a guy that just goes like this a
quick little zig heil
real quick oh [ __ ] these guys are still
zig highland bro
yeah that is so crazy music go ahead
probably like three days ago
i did it right to my daughter she's like
sick and she's like yes daddy yes
daddy yes no yeah dude
that's [ __ ] bananas that'll never go
out of style that [ __ ] yeah that's
that's here to stay
unfortunately
you know what's funny when i saw the the
mayor giuliani thing
yeah is that his name giuliani yeah
first of all
the way they kind of set it up i am
going to say this and i'm going i'm not
defending him by the way because
it's weird that he would they would go
into a room together and all this other
stuff right which was already awkward
right
because i think a lot of people are
dismissing his um
hand gesture stuff like paddington
they're like it was like a grand
your an old grandpa doing it to his uh
granddaughter right i'm like cool that's
not his granddaughter yeah
you know right this is what he thought
was a conservative reporter
so he should not be doing that in the
first place yeah the thing where i will
say that it is blown out of proportion i
think sasha baron cohen said like
no he was gonna i think he doubled down
and says like i think he was gonna do
loot stuff if i didn't step
in yeah is when he when she was like
looking for the mic or whatever trying
to pull out the mic and his shirt came
out and he leaned back
and he said that he was tucking in his
shirt i actually believe he was tucking
in his shirt
the reason why is because people who
look at that
don't understand number one you've never
been lobbed up before and number two
was was that what the whole thing was it
was a love so he
you've never been lobbed up before and
you also never been fat trying to tuck
in your shirt so this is coming from a
fat person
okay when you're fat and you have a
belly you cannot tuck in your shirt
sitting down
it's impossible yeah because you have
this [ __ ] globe
in front of you and it's hard so when i
was fat and i had to tuck in my shirt i
didn't want to stand up
i had to lean back and tuck in my shirt
just like he did okay so when i saw that
i was like oh he's just tucking in his
shirt
but for other people who don't have that
fat belly issue you actually don't know
what it's like like we have to
stand up and then tuck in our shirt or
we have to lean back and do it yeah i
don't have that problem now but i know
what that is that's a fat person thing
because watching the whole situation
unfold of him trying
because the whole premise was he was
trying to
rudy gianni like borat was trying to get
his quote-unquote daughter in the film
to like have sex with time
with uh rudy giuliani she's 15 she's too
old she's too old
but like well obviously the whole
pretense is like
very crazy right yeah you know well that
being said because
it's a setup it's a sting 100 to frame
this guy
to like you know but it's all for the
bit whatever
but even like the leading up to it was
kind of the way it happened was kind of
like
what's really going on you don't really
know what's
what's happening yeah it is weird but
also too like bora
like sasha baracon whatever the [ __ ] his
name is yeah yeah
he likes respect for him he uh bruno he
definitely leans left right
oh yeah so so i mean and giuliani just
came out with those like hunter biden
[ __ ] ukraine emails
there's also like a political and
giuliani was the one that released those
though yeah that tape so yeah like
there's also like
everything is so politicized that like
it
you could see in the interview why he
would want to say like
like discredit giuliani by being like oh
he's going to pull his dick out [ __ ]
yeah
i mean so i i can see it's not like he's
not tainted by
politics himself 100 you know so when i
see that too and people kind of
immediately jump to you know julie like
i said i don't
know [ __ ] about mayor giuliani you know
what you know what i mean like that
being said though i would not be
surprised if he
liked that dude you know what i mean
like
all those politician dudes creep me
they've always creeped me out yeah i've
always been like all these guys look
like [ __ ] creeps is that how is no
one
tripping on this yeah we all look like
weirdos but also too it's like that's
how you become a politician
that she was quote unquote 15 she's
obviously not 15.
but i doubt that whole thing would have
happened why would you the pretense of
going to the back room obviously it's
like okay yeah i see where this is going
oh i thought he knew
that she was 15. no no no he didn't say
that until borax comes out
and he's like i'll have sex with like
have checked my own nose it's right yeah
with that being said borat won much
better
yo borat at one point you know what i
forgot that he
wrestled naked yeah with his buddy dude
that was the funniest [ __ ]
dude how do you know the first time
we're watching it we watched the second
one and she was like i didn't really
like it and then watched the first one
she was like this one's much better dude
yeah it was literally they were in each
other's taints
yeah 69 69 each other i think the big
dude was on top of him at
that point and he kept shoving his balls
on his
where he's at the he's at the dinner
with all the southern etiquette dinner
yeah the etiquette dinner
and he's talking he's like he's like
like your body is very sensual
you know and he says that and then the
pastor's like it's very true which was
kind of weird for him to say because
that wasn't even his wife
but then he says he's like in my country
they go crazy for you too
and then they're like oh everyone's
laughing he goes but this one
not so much that was his wife
and then he's like he's like he's
[ __ ]
so much but the second borat movie it
was funny like it was good there was
some
like the to me the more lighthearted
bits were really funny like when he
stays with the the two
uh the abortion clinic the abortion
clinic was
yeah that was probably one of the better
bits too um because they they go
in and she like swallows a baby or
something okay so what happens is like
so you know he's terrible yeah yeah
so throughout this whole film right his
daughter is considered chattel and
property like
in kazakhstan right so they create this
whole backstory where she has this
little children's book
where it teaches young girls like number
one yeah he's explaining his way
if you play with yourself you'll [ __ ]
die and go blind
super over the top like like [ __ ] like
this like women can drive
not even that dude the worst part is
like they go up into this like [ __ ]
cattle rancher and they're like
they get her a cage and she's excited to
for their new cage yeah
she's like will i be like princess
melania yeah she is the most uh lavish
uh wife of all time she's like is this
case just for me
like no other people in this she's like
she's up for it right and he has like a
collar on her has a dog bowl for her and
all this other [ __ ]
but he decides to get her a cupcake at
this cake shop right
and the funniest part is is the fact
that he's scared to give her a cupcake
because
people might find out that he's giving
his daughter treats which he's not
supposed to do
okay so he's making her eat this um it's
like this baby cupcake right where they
put like a toy baby on top that people
are about to
be pregnant so she eats it so fast she
swallows
the little baby and so he's like we have
to get a baby outside the view and so
they go to an abortion club oh my god
so they don't like a christian abortion
yep and they don't know that they're
talking about a plastic baby inside his
stomach and that he's talking about
she's like she wanted it so i had to
give her so i put the baby aside
he's like i'm her father and then she
goes
i knew people would be mad so we went
behind the dumpster and i give her the
baby
and i'm italian my name is giuseppe and
the guy's like
the whole time they're trying to coerce
him to say like
uh it doesn't matter how the baby got
into her but we must keep the baby
yeah so shining light on the whole fact
that like abortion you know
in certain cases should be allowed yeah
it's [ __ ] nuts dude yeah and it's
like
and the this guy is denying like no no
like you must not have an idea he's
trying to like thoroughly explain the
situation
he goes i don't want to hear the rest of
this like i don't want to hear the [ __ ]
like stop
stop yeah and he's just saying like i'm
a father because the baby's like inside
you're the father right he's like
the child once she was i had to put
inside her
he's like can we take the baby out yeah
damn and
the whole time it just like this this
guy is almost at a loss for words
because he's like
what the [ __ ] you know and who knows how
genuine these reactions are because
at the end of the day there's a camera
in the [ __ ] room yeah it's cut and
edited
yeah i think i think it's pretty good
yeah i think certain nerd because like i
did i saw like 15 20 minutes of it and
i saw the part where he's in the store
like and he starts looking at porn
and that guy legitimately looked like he
was pretty pissed yeah he was in the
bathroom
tall black man tall white woman or
whatever
you talk about cream pies yeah she's so
[ __ ]
it was funny as [ __ ] he's very unique i
don't see myself being able to do what
he does
and keep a straight face number one i'm
a [ __ ] i can't do [ __ ] like that number
two i would be
dying laughing yeah he had a show on
show time and he got like politicians to
like
bite the head off like dildos are you
talking about ali g
how did you know it was he was like an
israeli like defense
guy yeah what was it that was a movement
it would know it was a show
it was a show that's right yeah yeah and
he was like trying to say like
like i think donald trump is very smart
about like arming kids
with guns in the school and he was like
trying to get all these politicians to
do crazy [ __ ] yeah like to like agree
with him and like they're they kind of
were on board you know like actually
they were very on board
that he did he was he was like some kind
of like anti-terrorist specialist or
some [ __ ] right
so he's teaching them the camera he's
like daily dude it's like you're in a
dire situation you have to do what you
can to survive like if you're a hostage
so he puts a dildo on and he gets the
politician to
bite the dildo like saying like you you
have to like you have to bite penis off
and he's just like
he's going at the dildo dog it's
he made them say like some racist ass
[ __ ] and they were so completely
comfortable
what the [ __ ] how do you do that and
that's that's the power of like the
borat stuff like because he's so good at
like making these people feel
comfortable to say crazy [ __ ] that's so
wild like he goes to like a hardware
store and he's like uh how many gypsy
can i kill with this bottle of uh with
propane like how many juices can i get
he's like you think i could kill 20.
he's like oh you need to what am i
following
oh the the cage one he takes it bro he
takes
the daughter to go buy a cage at this
hardware store and he's like
he's like oh this is very good like
trump put mexican in cage
and he's like and he's like high five
and the guy's like yup but
donald trump did do that high five and
i'm just like
yo that's crazy but you know what is
what it is
oh my god there's some really
interesting moments in there
i'm trying to remember the another part
that [ __ ] got me well the [ __ ]
menstruation thing the [ __ ] yeah that
[ __ ]
oh bro when so they go to like a daddy
daughter ball right in the south
somewhere
okay and it's i guess it's like if they
walk down the aisle
and they say like who this lady is the
father of so and so i don't know what
the purpose of it is
is it to like i don't know auctionize
your daughter for some weird stuff to
like find suitors like oh well like
she's really i don't know it's like
matchmaker [ __ ]
okay she's walking down the aisle and
they're like listing her accomplishments
and she goes
and they're like she studies at grand
canyon university
she studies she majors in cage
maintenance
and also vcr repair and like they're
saying this
and everyone at the like they're just
like oh okay they do this
daddy daughter dance is ridiculous
because she's she's [ __ ] on her
period
and then as she's dancing they're doing
this russian leg kick up [ __ ] right
but blood everything they called moon
cycle
and everybody's mortified wow
like she he goes up to the one of the
dads with his daughter there
and she's and he's like he's like how
much you think my daughter's worth like
you think like
he's like 900 dollars he's like very
nice
and then the daughter's like dad what
the [ __ ] she was like what the [ __ ] like
you can't say [ __ ] like yeah she's like
getting mad at this wolf
and he's just like like like laughing it
off it's so ridiculous
even like small [ __ ] like uh when they
were trying to get her to look pretty
like melania trump right and she goes to
a salon to get her hair cut she's like
it's like they're asking for a trim and
then she was like oh show me here
let me see your hair and then she lifts
up herself she goes nope not that it's
just
a bush like a crazy bush you just gotta
watch a little bit just like that
like i said i don't watch 15 minutes of
it and i was like that that one scene
was funny but i i'll power through and
watch because that [ __ ] sounds [ __ ]
crazy
yeah it gets it's uncomfortable tiff had
anxiety afterwards
i mean but all these [ __ ] even like
bruno like brutal when they have the mma
fight and they start making out in the
south
and everyone starts throwing chairs and
bottles and [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] that [ __ ] makes me laugh oh my
god dude or the swinger party
did you have you seen bruno no i haven't
seen bruno is good i'm actually going to
watch it tonight
so in bruno i think he goes to he's like
trying to not be gay or some [ __ ] like
that's like the premise of the movie
i i think that's like one of the
presents [ __ ] ridiculous and so he
goes to like the
prey the gay away thing and then at one
point he goes to a swinger party and
see people are [ __ ] like they were
like yeah in rooms [ __ ]
and he's like trying to pretend to act
like he wants to [ __ ] he doesn't want to
[ __ ] this girl because he's gay yeah so
he's like keeps going up to like
different guys they're
literally in the middle of [ __ ] he's
like so how do you how what
how how do you do that like what are you
he's like having conversations and the
guy's [ __ ] he's like yo you want to
get the [ __ ] away from me
you're [ __ ] off dude i'm [ __ ] right
bro i remember he had that show ali g in
the house or i don't know if that was
the movie but he had a show on hbo
and he's interviewing this basketball
player i forgot who it was but he's like
he's like doing his thing he's like ali
g right and he's like so
you're telling me like this ball how
does this ball bounce
and then the guy it was like uh there's
air in it you know like the air
it bounces because of the air he's like
well there's air in this whole room
why isn't it bouncing
and it just cuts like in the basketball
player and then just cuts
so good
that's [ __ ] nuts man like it's it's
interesting when you watch somebody that
he
is the chappelle of what he does yeah
yeah there will be
another sasha but also who's like i
gotta say this for my guy because i love
him so much
eric andre andre's good too he's so good
at that [ __ ]
there's this one stick that he does
where he's getting chased by a cop
and he runs into a store oh they're like
oh my god oh my god freeze free freeze
and he handcuffs him they're like in
front of everybody
the coffee shop person yeah yeah the
guy's hank eric andre gets handcuffed
he the cop turns around and they look at
each other
and then they start looking deeply into
into each other's eyes and they start
making out
like legit like hard on me you know
everyone's like yo what the [ __ ] like
what
and then and then there's they pan over
to this one girl
that works at the store she's just like
so happy she's like
and this one guy's like yo what the [ __ ]
call the cops he's like call the cops
and
he's pissed and then eric andre stops
and he and they both point at him they
go i'm gonna [ __ ] that guy
and he's like he's like like he freaks
the [ __ ] out bro it's so
funny the stuff so you want to show us
people are homophobic they're [ __ ]
homophobic though
yeah it's crazy when they when like well
i understand from like a heterosexual
standpoint like when you see another guy
make out it doesn't seem natural to yeah
you know i mean because
we like women so when we see that it
makes us feel weird it's like it's like
against what we like yeah so it's like
oh [ __ ] but even girls i know
they don't like seeing dudes make out
they just don't like it i think these
guys are just gross in general so when
you see guys just [ __ ] bumping uglies
yeah
weird thing to look at okay when two
girls kiss it's like this is this is
beautiful
homophobia we should talk about [ __ ]
well you said like the chris pratt thing
yeah he's getting in trouble apparently
he's his so that [ __ ] was from 2019.
yeah cause i was so i guess so we were
talking about this earlier
and apparently people they did this is
how this is how kick
like [ __ ] kicks up it all starts on
[ __ ] twitter bro like literally
nonsense so apparently
they did a poll over the weekend i don't
know what like celebrity news list did
this but they were like
who are the best chris you have to pick
three out of the four
or some [ __ ] it was like chris pine
chris evans captain america my guy
uh chris hemsworth thor also my guy and
then chris pratt
you know what's his name on the
guardians of the galaxy
star lord he's great too and everybody
was like
like boo chris pratt [ __ ] that guy
because i i guess in 2019
uh he was talking about his uh he was on
the colbert show or some [ __ ]
and he was talking about his faith or
something like that he was talking about
this very specific diet that he's on
right that he learned from either his
pastor or his church
it's like some biblical ass diet right i
don't know exactly
grain nuts and lots of bread ezekiel
bread
and then the blisters of jesus christ
and so he was eating high protein
yeah so uh and he was talking about how
it helped him out a lot
and something along the lines of ellen
page saw the stephen colbert thing right
and he was talking about his diet and
then she was like well
if you're going to talk about your
church you know we should probably
address the fact that your church hates
gay people and it's [ __ ] wrong
but it's like wait hold on a second dude
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
him talking about his
diet right like you literally took
something that he said bastardize it and
you're attacking this dude on a public
platform for [ __ ] what
yeah right and so people are latching on
to that old tweet saying that he's a
hateful human being because
the church that he goes to hates gay
people which by the way isn't true
yeah right she says okay um but his
church is infamously anti-lgbtq
so maybe address that too question mark
so i'm like where the [ __ ] do you come
out the [ __ ] woodwork dude
and attack somebody
if you are a famous actor and you belong
to an organization that hates a certain
group of people
don't be surprised if someone simply
wonders why it's not addressed
being anti-lgbtq is wrong
there aren't two sides the damage it
causes is severe
full stop sending love to all but the
dumb [ __ ] okay well how dare you though
like that is the most worst way to think
ever number one
that just creates enemies right so i
could we could pick apart what
anybody does right right for her too
right i was like okay
well you're a part you're an actress
right aren't you a part of this machine
this machine in hollywood that excludes
asian people and black people exactly so
how about we talk about that [ __ ] or
you're a white
yeah or you're [ __ ] white what if i
just talk about yeah you could literally
pick anything and just go after it
yeah it's the most virtue signaling
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my [ __ ]
life
exactly so when people when someone
posted this dumbass tweet like one has
to go
and then he has four pictures of all the
chris's right which okay who the [ __ ]
exactly what lame [ __ ] posted that
yeah like who's so stupid
[ __ ] chris evans you got to stay
focused yeah yeah
why even question it yeah yeah yeah and
hemsworth those are my guys
but also people getting all mad and
they're saying sorry this disqualifies
him because he's a
he's a trump supporter so he's getting
in trouble for being a trump supporter
and being
anti-gay uh based off his
he's based off the church that he goes
to but i guess they fact checked it
and then he's never ever talked about
his political side yeah he's actually
like quite libertarian he's
he's been on record apparently saying
like i actually don't support both sides
i feel like
both has their cons both both
too much very nice my back [ __ ] better
tie
and he goes you know they both have
their flaws and both have their their
pros
but i'm not really like he doesn't speak
out on anybody that sounds very
reasonable yeah
he's not a reasonable human being yeah
and then and then he's saying like
apparently he donated to barack obama's
campaign in 2012
and he's never been a democrat or a
republican he's actually a libertarian
why does he have to bring out his
receipts like that right exactly why
right and even if let's say listen
people already know
i do not like trump right but why do i
have to hate somebody because they like
him
right he gives a [ __ ] right like
whatever he's doing pro
obviously speaks to them on some kind of
[ __ ] level yeah right right like i
disagree with you but i'm not going to
go out of my way to [ __ ]
just trash you about it yeah right i'm
not going to hate you as a human
being that's the problem like you put
somebody on the map
about all this [ __ ] these you you say
he's doing all these things
but it's not true there's no proof of
this and then people are still smearing
him to this day about this happened a
year ago
i guess from my my recent research and
this is his quote he
says my faith is very important to me
but no church defines me or my life
in fact i am not a spokesman for any
church or a group of people
my values define who i am we need less
hate in the world
not more a man who believes that
everyone is entitled to love who they
want
free from the judgment of their fellow
man that sounds
very reasonable that sounds very
enlightened and i know
and very dope it's like like if i were
to be his anger translator what he's
saying is how [ __ ] dare you you [ __ ]
yeah right
i'm over here chilling doing my own
thing and you over here coming at me
yeah right star-lord would never do that
bro he would never do that i know suck
at my crumb
yeah bro [ __ ] all that whoever's saying
he's or he's a racist and all that [ __ ]
they're back [ __ ] not very people
i don't understand how people jump on
these like because they clearly
they're wrong so they don't know the
facts and but they jump
so wholeheartedly and like yeah he is a
[ __ ] racist he is a trump supporter
he's like you're like you don't even
have the facts
yeah and you're like so wholeheartedly
like [ __ ] carrying the battle axe
like you know
everything about this dude ellen page
two like you know who you are
you know your position you know how
powerful you can be when you tweet
something like that
right you went out of your way to just
to try and destroy somebody's career for
[ __ ] what what was your objective
that's what i want to ask her yeah what
was the point what were you going to do
in like do you know what i'm saying yeah
right exactly at the end of the day
where you're trying to say [ __ ] you
chris pratt i'm gonna show you what's up
right right it's gotten to the point now
where she whatever
you know she's identifying with is
becoming bigger than being a decent
human being
right and that's the problem is that
everyone's identifying more with their
team or being woke or whatever the [ __ ]
or being
whatever it's just sports it's like
dodgers versus
the [ __ ] angels like it's like it's
literally like i hate you because you're
on the other side like yeah
it's so disappointing stupid it was so
disappointing and and and i
what's even more disappointing is that
it gains steam and that people don't
look at it and go shut the [ __ ] up and
that's the narrative
everyone's like it was like [ __ ] chris
shut up you know biggest thing
here's the greatest example of this
right because you know recently the uh
the
fires that happened yeah it was because
of the gender reveal parties right yeah
so one dude wrote a comment on my thing
right and i tried i didn't trash him i
just explained to him oh you trashed him
what do you say no he
would he what he wrote
what he wrote was like well gender
reveal parties happened because
this lady she before she could find the
the gender of her baby her baby had to
be considerably aborted or it kept dying
before birth
yeah and i was like hold on a second
that sounds like in my but when i read
that i was like this sounds like the
most ridiculous [ __ ] i've ever heard
in my life right
did one google search right i looked at
every interview and article of this lady
and she the reason why she did that is
because
and to quote her she says i like
celebrating things
i'm like where did you find this
information right exactly i did some
back research and it was from a [ __ ]
tweet some
jackass wrote this tweet doc i'm telling
you twitter
is the worst is the worst information
yeah
this guy wrote this long tweet i'm not
sure if it was a joke or whatever but it
got retweeted a gajillion [ __ ] times
yeah everybody attached themselves to it
and said you guys are all [ __ ] for
thinking that gender repeal
reveal parties are dumb because this
lady had multiple um
uh [ __ ] miscarriages yeah because she
couldn't find out what the gender the
baby is
and all she said on multiple interviews
through multiple news facets
that i just like celebrating [ __ ] right
which i respect the honesty
exactly i like having parties bro and
also it's annoying but
whatever the guy that commented on the
video why is he so
like in love with gender reveal parties
why does he feel like he has to defend
it oh because they want to say something
right
so everybody can pat him on the back say
you are an amazing [ __ ] person but
you are so right and also it makes you
look like an [ __ ] yeah like
like oh it's because of a good cause and
[ __ ] you and i'm good because i suck
how about that right and also that
dude like how the lack of sorry the lack
of self-awareness though the lack of
self-awareness to be like
touch my test because i've i've said
[ __ ] where i was like i don't really
know what i'm saying but i'm saying it
like i know what i'm saying but yeah
still that voice is like in the back of
my head saying you don't really know
what the [ __ ] is that
exactly exactly where is that voice in
that guy and these people because they
they clearly that dude's wrong
so he he obviously it doesn't know the
facts like where the [ __ ] is that voice
to be like
yo maybe you should delete this because
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
yeah you're wrong people like where is
that voice
it's like i'm saying sometimes dude like
i'm a part of this
you know we're all a part of this well
you guys are not too we're all a part of
this moving machine and social media
right
a lot of it i do enjoy because some of
the funniest [ __ ] comes out of it
sure but also the terrible things that
come out of it are
so bad it irritates my [ __ ] soul
right so
it's it's also exposing to now that i'm
seeing it and when i see some of these
people
face to face like i start to understand
how people could develop these fake
personalities online because it's easier
to do stuff without having to face the
repercussions of what you're saying
of course you know the internet is a
free place to just say whatever you want
and nothing will happen to you yeah this
podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha not all matcha is curated and
created the same and jun b matcha stands
out above the rest
if your matcha isn't a beautiful shade
of green and doesn't have an earthy
smooth taste then you are definitely not
having junebe
matcha is not supposed to be bitter the
caffeine boosts and health benefits you
get from it are the best no caffeine
jitters and loaded
with a bunch of antioxidants to get 10
off your first order of tins and packets
go to junebeshop.com and enter code
geniusbrain once again that's 10 off
your first order of tins and packets go
to junebeshop.com and enter code
geniusbrain one of my clients uh she
used to live in miami and she was
telling me a story about how like
in miami in certain parts of town
obviously it's a little you know
dangerous
and they were walking with a big group
of girls and like one guy
this one guy passing by grabbed this
girl in the ass
and was like oh what's up mommy like you
know whatever yeah and the guy was like
the guy of the group said yo what the
[ __ ] and started fighting with this guy
and then three other guys came out they
started beating the [ __ ] out of this guy
you know the uh what do you call that
the
the parking meter they started kicking
it down
tore it off out of the ground and start
beating him
with this [ __ ] oh holy [ __ ] dude like
and just beating like three guys there's
no honor in that though blood yeah yeah
you could say there's no honor all you
want about [ __ ]
but people don't truly understand the
reality of violence yeah you've never
known this you really don't know
i'm lucky that my dad had gotten in
enough street fights and told me these
stories when i was like
way too young to hear him but like where
they like scarred in my head yeah
but he would tell me his cradle hush
little baby
don't get stabbed
bro papa kills somebody he got whacked
you know papa got bars yeah he got a
fire
bro he would tell me crazy stories i
loved him because i was like
i was five and like six and i was like
this is the craziest [ __ ] stories i
heard
but i definitely like he would tell me
like
he he taught me young not to like [ __ ]
with people like his
his main thing was like if you go
looking for trouble he's like never
being he was like never be an [ __ ]
because you want me to be an [ __ ] but
he was like
never go looking for trouble because
like you will run into the wrong
[ __ ] 100
eventually you will and then he looked
at me and he was like i've been that
wrong [ __ ] for some people
i thought he was gonna say that he ran
into the wrong [ __ ] he's like
no i'm the wrong [ __ ] he's like
i've been and i was like
all right dad like i want to go play
tags
it's like dad uh kindergarten starts
tomorrow
well you're scaring everybody in my
class pat's dad
he's about that action bro yeah he's
about that [ __ ] used to tell me these
crazy stories about like guys and i
could tell like
like it he would just tell me the real
[ __ ] that he saw growing up like dudes
getting stabbed and dudes
this and that and he's like you never
know and he would always be like the
thing about a fight in the streets is
like you literally
never know someone could have a gun
somebody bought a knife bat that could
be
four or five dudes he's like you never
know like and he was always honest too
he's like if you gotta run [ __ ] run
like if there's too many if they're
you're in a situation where it's like
yeah there's no macho man [ __ ]
you'll die you know like if there's six
guys
rumble in the bronx you saw what
happened to jackie chan bro bro that was
the corner
and they [ __ ] threw bottles at that
floor and let me tell you something so
the the girl that i was dating before
muriel um i remember i was dropping no i
was picking her up at
uh at lax right dropping her off i don't
know either way
but she getting rid of her was being was
being hit on by this big ass dude right
and you could tell that she was
feeling a little uncomfortable like the
guy was kind of being aggressive right
and my ass was like looking at the
situation thinking about it two ways so
there's
there's one thing that could happen
either one you're gonna be the boyfriend
to stand up for your lady
right or number two you're gonna be the
comic and making this to a funny
situation mm-hmm so what did i choose
the concept so i saw that i was like oh
and i
ran and i went behind a pillar right and
i'm cracking the [ __ ] up right because
what nothing's going to happen to it
right
but i saw her i guess you're looking
around for me like yo where'd this guy
go
where's my knight in shining armor and
then i'm literally texting him
i text her i'm like hey where are you at
right she goes this guy is hitting on me
can you come over here and
you know tell him to leave me alone and
i was looking at this situation it
wasn't that bad she's not used to like
[ __ ] dudes coming up to her like that
and i'm cracking the [ __ ] up i was like
hold on i'm gonna send a picture of
myself to scare him away right and i
sent her a picture of terry crew's butt
naked with a basketball
talk she was mad at me for like a month
like she was so [ __ ] bad
there's a leftover there i just left it
there and i sent a picture of terry
crews half naked i was like send in this
photo tell him ted is your boyfriend
and then she's sitting there i can see
her pissed when she saw the tag she's
like
but it probably worked though did she
show the picture well no she just told
the guys like i'm not really interested
he walked away i was like that's all you
had to do like if she was in a very
uncomfortable that would be
so funny though she was like this is
actually my boyfriend she's a holy [ __ ]
you know terry crews
[ __ ] this guy he lives in pasadena yeah
but yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious i i
got into a lot of trouble in my
relationships because i i would joke
around
so much but like i always needed to be
with somebody that could take
jokes right of course because i don't
like being in serious situations because
when things get serious i'll get mad
like i don't want to do that yeah
david's gonna stab somebody with a
[ __ ] toenail clipper
i will not i'm actually docile i'm very
docile now
yeah okay okay
oh this is fun david this is fun day we
like this baby
sweet tea
from the chris meme dude yeah that's so
stupid i don't understand how you could
just
just actively search for [ __ ] in
somebody's past to make them feel
terrible
that's what everyone's about nowadays
why i don't like it because it's it's uh
who's next
who do you think it's about looking good
to your to your team
it's about seeming like a good person
it's about seeming more woke or whatever
the [ __ ] it is like it's just about
like she shits on him she looks like a
good person because she's standing up
for
uh lgbt community or whatever and like
now she gets social paths and is like oh
i get to feel like a good person for two
days that's her buzz you know what i
mean like that's
that's some people everyone has their
buzz right some people stand up comedy
some people it's whatever
having a beer her buzz is seeming like a
good [ __ ] person you know so
it's [ __ ] so lame and it sucks too
because like
i remember when myspace came out i was
like in sixth or seventh grade like sure
was dope
we had no problems like that on myself
even then though because i was in the
transition from like it used to just be
you know just kicking it so like just
social was just
hanging out in the park and [ __ ] and
then it was like oh my space came out
and this and that
but even back then i knew like this is
just for fun like
social media is just supposed to be for
fun yeah like
i mean you can you can make it work for
your business and stuff like that and
that's cool i don't mind that at all but
at the end of the day the whole thing is
like this is just for entertainment
purposes
like at least that's the way i always
looked at it and people some of the
folks take it
so seriously dude like they have no
social skills they like don't develop
their own
human like their own individuality like
they're all this [ __ ] just
this projection i don't know how many
times i've
seen people online and met them in
person and they
are literally a fraction of the the
bravado that they have
in these videos because they're shooting
with themselves right and you meet them
in person
and i'm like well i go this person is
going to be you know pretty cool to be
around
they open their mouth they've never
spoken to a human being in their life
it's like you are the biggest [ __ ]
loser i've ever been
yeah how how do you go around living
like this
and it's true too in the sense of
here's like the biggest warning i have
for creators right especially in this
space i've been in this space now what
11 years right it's a very
long [ __ ] time and i'm still making
good money off of this stuff
so i may not be like at the biggest
right but longevity wise 11 years is a
very [ __ ] long time right and even
before that doing standard since i was
16 it even goes even further back
so there's there's like creators now
where they don't realize after why after
four or five years they're left with
nothing
and the reason why is because when you
create based on what other people
say about how amazing you are that
well runs dry fast it runs out super
[ __ ] quick and then you end up with
nothing at all
you don't know who your friends are
right you you value yourself on what
other people said about you and now that
you're not getting the same validation
now you're like
am i a [ __ ] loser do people not like
me it's like
this stuff doesn't [ __ ] matter if you
know how to use this space and do what
you want and then move out after you
won't have to feel these feelings
i've had the same [ __ ] friends since
i was in high school till this day
do this day just do it to this day we
[ __ ] have thanksgiving together we
have christmas together and we've been
meeting up each other since we were 14
and it hasn't stopped
and so when people come into the
stitches that's right
they can't get rid of you that's right
they gotta admit pat right now you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but you know that's what i'm saying
like it's weird when when they're like
oh like oh
like when you go back to sacramento who
you're gonna kick it with i'm like
friends my homies i have friends you
guys don't have
[ __ ] friends what are you talking
about so they'll stay in los
angeles because they have nobody to go
back to back at home i'm like so this
whole time
you've never developed a proper
relationship right yeah and like i was
talking to this other kid too recently
where he was upset because
uh he got into an argument with some new
friends that he met in la
and he was just [ __ ] about [ __ ]
on people here and i'm like listen dude
you're you're you're awkward too right
because
you're you're asking me for advice about
how to deal with this personal
friendship with somebody that you met
for [ __ ] a month they're not your
friends they're right yeah for real you
know the fact that you called him your
homie
and a good homie and i asked you how
long you've known me it's been a month
and a half a month
shows you that you're [ __ ] weird that
is not your friend yeah right
you're using david to tell you the real
truth right for real it's like you're
surprised about somebody's behavior when
you don't know who they are
right how dumb are you yeah exactly you
know put yourself in that position
exactly i'm not surprised when somebody
i don't know [ __ ] me over
because i don't know this person right
and they don't owe me [ __ ] so it's like
yeah right what were you in it for in
this relationship you guys
gathered together to create content
together and
that was it that's the basis of your
friendship you guys are using each other
yeah exactly because you could tell a
lot about somebody
based off their friends you know you
meet the people that they hang out with
and you're like
oh you were very interesting
you know like like a lot of red flags i
was talking about this with tiff the
other day
like whenever you meet somebody and
they're like really mean to like
wait staff or people at restaurants
they're like
oh you're you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah
like the way you talk to people is very
interesting the biggest
factor too that you'll see with people
it's it's how somebody treats somebody
based on what their status is if they
treat right somebody they can't get
anything out of the same way they treat
somebody that they are getting something
out of you
that's a good person exactly because
it's just based off their relationship
is based off what they see that person
as versus what they can get from exactly
right we were talking about that today
about people that because david is a
person of interest right people like
david david has a huge following
so there's a lot of people in active
following p there's a lot of people that
you can see
that try to talk to dave and they're
like really like they're too nice to
david or they're too nice of somebody
right and you're like why are you doing
that like overly nice where it doesn't
feel genuine at all
and there's nothing grosser than when
you see someone trying to build a
relationship with somebody
purely out of like opportunity and
nothing especially when you're trying to
do it with a z-list celebrity
like dog you're a loser i am at the
lowest totem pool that celebrity is
and you're trying to get something out
of me you [ __ ] loser
you all stay healthy yeah it's not true
but stay humble
it's just [ __ ] hilarious so we were
talking about this one specific guy and
the reason why i never liked him when i
first met him was because this guy was
laughing at [ __ ] that wasn't jokes that
i was saying
like he was a thirsty ass girl all right
you know what i mean like i was saying
something he goes
you're so funny and i'm like i looked at
him and i just said i didn't say a joke
what's funny
he's like you know you funny yeah just
know where you are
wow yeah dude and i mean in the
entertainment industry
i've seen that a lot in comedy too uh
especially when there's like a bigger
comedian around everyone's just like
writing this dude's sack that's why i've
always felt weird like if i've seen like
a bigger comic or whatever
i've always been like i just try to let
it happen naturally like if we end up
talking and we talk that's cool but i've
never been like the chummy
because i i i i dropped this spies like
that that
that like trying to get something out of
you
thing like yeah yeah like i would never
want to be like they have their friends
in their circle
they're going to help them out first
before you even come around right you
know
and also just like ugh yeah being like
that is just so gross
kind of i ignore them so hard i make
them think that i [ __ ] hate them dude
yeah that's what i do
dude there's a lot of people too you
meet and and like if you just look at
him as the human not like the comedian
or what or whatever it is that you think
you want to be
uh you ice you start realizing like this
guy sucks
he has a piece of [ __ ] like i met a lot
of dudes where i was like actually i
don't really like that guy yeah
i'm like i don't want to be around that
guy i went up to dave chappelle i was
like mr chappelle
i don't know who you are like how did
you know my name yeah [ __ ]
i love six and stones when you leave i
played it too cool
get out of the situation now and i just
closed my hands over my face like i
disappeared like oh she's like
i can still see you no if i can't see
you you can't see me that's how it works
like bill burr goes up to david hey
you're really funny that's a cool
[ __ ] story
yeah yeah i don't even know bill burr
remembers this but i did a little quick
stand-up set and ice house passed in and
he told me i was funny that's
[ __ ] amazing and i almost shot myself
yeah
and at that time i was like why is he
talking to me yeah bro that's the
greatest credit
that's amazing and i thought my set was
pretty terrible but you know maybe he
saw something funny in it
but i think i think probably the bit
that he liked was me making fun of
people because i used to have glasses at
the time right and i did this whole bit
about how i used to [ __ ] hate it when
people would come up to me and say well
your eyes are bad and take off my
glasses and put it on their face it's
like [ __ ]
now i can't see yeah you don't need any
more evidence
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
doing like would you walk up to somebody
in a wheelchair kick them
the [ __ ] out and then sit down and start
rolling out the way like oh you really
are [ __ ] paralyzed
like [ __ ] oh this really is a
wheelchair
like flopping so i had this little bit
on that i think that's the bit that he
liked yeah
well i mean guys like that yeah that are
like [ __ ] [ __ ]
guys that are on that level can see like
because they're so good and they're so
experienced like even though something
might a joke might be like in a in its
raw form or whatever because you're so
new
they can see the spark of funny you know
they understand like oh this guy's got
something
you know so that's that could be it too
yeah but that's the greatest [ __ ]
compliment dude but like a bill bird
[ __ ]
funny that's i would ponder sweating too
i was like i'd be like i'm gonna make it
even say much either he was like that
[ __ ] was pretty funny i'm like
oh my god i was like oh [ __ ] what did
you say
bro yeah dude yeah dude that's amazing
that's a [ __ ] honor right you're
korean bill bird now
honorable korean bird he says stuff this
is like
i can't think like that he's so [ __ ]
good he's always thinking on you i love
bill burr
am i just surface level comparison yeah
i mean i'm like damn how do you like
take it from here to that
next level yeah you know because you i
think general comics can make people
laugh yeah but how you make somebody
think and laugh do they piss in their
pants right
that makes you an amazing that's yeah
that's where the genius comes yeah and
the chapelles the the carlin's the
billboards like that like that's
if you can make a [ __ ] think and
they're like learning and
funny like that's that's [ __ ] crazy
that's so wild
he takes like the the very unlikable
topics
and makes it and he goes head on dude he
takes it
and he runs with it and he makes it
funny and he makes like a very good
point about it and he's likeable yeah
he's being an [ __ ] but he's likable
at the scene he loves how to teeter that
line too because
you have to listen to what he's saying
there's no hate in it
it's jokes yeah you know what i mean
with just high level observation
right so if you're looking to be
offended then you're going to get off
any kind of comic club when you walk in
and you you you have this attitude of
i'm looking for trouble you're going to
find it in the comments oh 100
yeah [ __ ] of course that's what that
place is
yeah that's what it's for that's what
it's for it's to relieve the pressure
and say the question
to a comedy comedy a club and not try to
laugh who are you you psychopath
this guy right here and i'm like that
wasn't funny no i would have comics sit
there
and clearly this other comic is killing
it and they're just not laughing i'm
like how are you not laughing that
shit's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah yeah there's a lot of that too like
i'm dying laughing listening to this
[ __ ] like i was when i when i used to do
comedy clubs i would
never like wait in the green i would
chill and i would watch other people set
and i would just
die laughter yeah yeah they could use
their jokes right after yeah
jokes and like that's my joke not
anymore it's
my joke but yeah no i do the same [ __ ]
because uh one it's fun to watch but two
you learn
from other people too it's like watching
fights it's the same thing
you're watching how they interact
because they might have a joke that goes
wrong how do they recover how do they
deal with the crowd how
how do they deal with the noisy
[ __ ] like you learn from
watching
you know what one of the worst feelings
is is like when i when i was like
super late at night and i would start
writing this [ __ ] set in a joke and
i'm cracking up laughing like yo this is
going to kill right oh yeah and i go up
on stage nobody laughs i'm like damn you
suck bro
like scratch a scratch scratch and i go
home and i'm like
idiot why did you think that was funny
no
[ __ ] stupid joke bro that happens
yeah
that's never happened to me on stage is
the crazy part
sometimes it's hard you saying my set
because they're so busy chanting my name
wow
and it's just at the end of the day it's
just so hard to be that good because
you're saying i want to suck your hair
and i'm like
i'm sorry i have no idea i know that
your first name was loser
loser throw tomatoes that you ate
yourself
they're like you need some vitamin c ah
thank you
yeah that would be so easy and i'm the
best at cause literally the worst
feeling on earth like
i remember when that the first i can
remember what it felt like when i was
bombing and i just felt this chill wash
over my whole body like
you need it's like that fight or flight
situation like you are not going to be
able to turn this around nobody loves
you
he knows what that feels like it's the
worst feeling on earth and then you just
have to have one buddy come up he's like
hey man
yeah it was a good job like this shut up
you know that [ __ ] was bad bro
[ __ ] talk to me yeah i've never had
that
that that chill way for me is a heat
wave
and i've even had it to the point
sometimes where like i'll nervous laugh
or whatever
and i'll be like oh like they know now
100
that i'm not recovering i started
learning this [ __ ] just from this one
little
trick from [ __ ] conan is where he
makes a bad joke and he shits on himself
real fast that's a good yeah it helped
me to recalibrate
so funny yeah but you only have so many
of those you got one of those you got
like one
maybe like disgusting you better [ __ ]
bring it around to some funny [ __ ]
because they'll they'll laugh at the
first one
yep then it's like that's true wait is
this all you're actually not and then
it's like
okay now you're you're done you're gonna
suffer for the rest of this [ __ ] set
dog it's it's it's [ __ ] fun i've kept
trying to do it over and over and
they're like nah
first off the stage funny second one
okay a little cute
you're done this ain't funny bro you
suck
it's hard man instead of [ __ ] about
probably it's
top five hardest things you could ever
do when i've seen a part of a group of
people for sure and the crazy thing is
people don't talk about some of these
bigger comics they talk about too is
like yo i still bomb to this day
yeah i'm like really yeah yeah how the
[ __ ] do you bomb
like i think people just laugh at you
for the [ __ ] of it dog
that's what's so sick about it though
yeah it's such a real thing that it's
like you you might get
even if you're a big dude like you might
get one or two like charity laughs but
then it's like
you really can't you gotta make
[ __ ] laugh did you tell me that
[ __ ] billboard [ __ ] on
brendan's shop live yeah somebody uh
told me a story
about how um he did a set and then
afterwards bill burr was like
hey guys if the jokes aren't funny don't
laugh
he's like because he has to learn he has
to learn
that's what we're saying he goes oh it's
not funny i know he has
ufc ears and [ __ ] but you know if it's
not funny
don't laugh because he's not gonna learn
it's true i mean it is it's true
because it's like look brendan shaw has
a such a massive following all the
people that go to his show
are probably just fans of the podcast
yeah the stuff that he does because he
he's a content machine he puts out
all this [ __ ] so it's like i'm sure
people that's why people [ __ ] on his
comedy right people get really mad at
him
because it's like he's he's kind of
built an echo chamber of shows
yeah and just people that love to see
him that'll that love him so much that
they'll laugh at anything that he
probably does
and they want to be supportive and it's
like a good thing but at the same time
it's like
in comedy if you're not making people
genuinely laugh
then there's no market for you right
yeah and i've you know what i saw
like i said like i've seen his stand up
i saw stuff like at house and stuff too
and i think maybe it could be a little
bit of some people being salty but i
think for me
i don't have any reason to feel salty
towards him at all like i have my own
personal success so when i see him
i'm just looking to laugh because i
enjoyed him on joe rogan's podcast
so i expect and i think what happens is
that joe amplifies his funny
yeah right so they have good funny
banter but when it's time for him to be
funny alone and on a stage
yeah that's where he that something's
lacking being funny in conversation
i'm sure is vastly different than being
funny
on stage in front of people where all
the attention's on you you're having a
[ __ ] 15-minute monologue right
because it's not it's not the same
it's not the same not the same it's not
the same i'm getting nervous talking
about standard i know like i could only
do that right now
i just remembered how bad it felt that
i'm like i'll never do this again dude
it's definitely not the same because you
have to like
you're starting from literally just i'm
a guy
go yeah like who are you okay now you
got to start making me laugh
like go yeah uh once like
like for me what i realized too is when
i have a bad start the rest of the set
is [ __ ]
like it's hard for me to dig out of it
it is well that's what all these comics
say right it's like if you
bomb the first joke you're just hard
people
people leave you so the hardest part is
turning the crowd right then that's what
everyone says is like
wow this dude turned the crowd like bro
i've seen amazing i've seen
you you can do it though it's just it's
just experience and there's certain
techniques
dude one time i went to the ice house to
see bill burr i i don't know if you were
there i think you were there when you
didn't show up yeah yeah we were there
so bill burr so we're watching the show
right funny show comics are going up
but we're like amped to see billboard
everyone's out there everyone it's sold
out ice house billboard [ __ ]
yeah but at some point
this dude comes out the host comes out
and he's like hey guys
i just want to let you know bill burr
said he couldn't make it today
uh so we're gonna refund your money or
we'll give you guys free tickets to a
future show you guys can use it and
people at first are like is this a joke
and they're like sorry and he he was
like nervous he's like this is not a
joke
and then people were born people are
like [ __ ] and you see yeah people start
getting up to leave
he's like but we got this other guy he's
funny dude like
give it up for his name was peter
something right he was just
peter get peter something gets up there
i feel bad not knowing his name because
he
he always think about this but he was
so funny people literally at first like
it was so amazing to watch especially
like as a fan of comedy and as a
comedian
because like at first people are talking
during the set the most lukewarm clap
like
people are like talking like what are we
gonna like this like what are we gonna
do now are we gonna go are we gonna stay
and this dude's trying to do comedy
right and he's like all right guys i
know you guys are pissed
you know like whatever [ __ ] me right
like
[ __ ] me right and like little by little
he started like getting people like
chuckle here
chuckle there chuckle here chuckle there
chocolate there and like about five
six minutes into it he had everyone's
attention and he started turning the
room
murdering it that's crazy murdering boom
boom
boom boom boom boom boom for like 30
minutes
because at some point the host came back
out and was like hey bill burr is gonna
come
you just got to keep going until he's
done yeah he's like all right [ __ ] it
right and then he just keeps going
and he like murdered it but he was
starting in the most
he was like yeah like worst situation
ever dude he would he would tell his
joke
and like he would say the joke no one's
listening he's like hey guys it was
funny because the punch line was this
and like it was funny to me who the
people that were paying attention it was
funny but
it's it's that's what's so cool about
comedy because i've seen it i've seen it
happen and i've i've kind of i've done
it myself too where there's a room that
isn't into your [ __ ] but like if you
have the right energy and the right [ __ ]
like you really can turn a [ __ ]
room around
like any it's possible you really can do
i mean there's some
instances where maybe it's not possible
but like i would say the majority of the
time it is possible you just have to
have the right technique it's like
fighting it's just the right moves to
get in there
one of the most annoying things because
of somebody who hasn't been through
like trying to do stand-up comedy like
when people
kind of look at it like it's easy it's
like have you ever been on stage bro
it's
have you ever been on stage before no
[ __ ] like it is very very difficult
you have to understand
there are you have to know how many
people want to be a stand-up comic but
don't make it
because not that many people are that
funny like there's people who are
yeah they make me laugh but are they
[ __ ] funny yeah are they good orators
can they speak well on a mic
that [ __ ] is hard to stutter all the
time i was like
like words that i know and i just
stuttered his own name
what's your name in conversation
that feeling of while you're talking to
somebody in conversation i'm like about
to start right now
and i'm just like like one time i
literally was just
like couldn't get the word out i would
fail a polygraph test so fast
yeah bro what is your name i was going
to a concert
i went to a black keys concert right and
everyone's checking ids and the guy goes
how old are you and i'm like 21 and i'm
like i'm sorry i'm not 21. i'm actually
25.
and he goes let me see your [ __ ] id
cause he wasn't checking ids and i i
don't know why i
i got nervous and i was like i'm 21. and
he goes don't ever defend me in court
ever dude
you [ __ ] have me incarcerated in a
second they'll be like
i'll step on the stand so did he do it
ah
i don't think so i don't i don't know i
don't i didn't get a good look
yo yo you're the key witness and i'm
just like i know but it was like dark
i don't know i'll just freak the [ __ ]
out and then i'm [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] in jail dude
somebody's taking my back [ __ ] and i
was like
but when you like stutter you [ __ ] up a
joke in front of a group of people and
then like a small group
like friends people that consider
friends and the way they look at you
afterwards is like
imagine that times a thousand in front
of a bunch of people that expect you to
be great that are paying money to see
you
paying money to see you it's bad bro i
remember i remember
dude in santa barbara like in the
beginning when i first started i was at
an open mic at a coffee shop and i was
saying some
stupid like not funny go ahead funny guy
tell us your jokes
i don't even remember what it was i just
remember saying it and thinking this
sucks and then i remember seeing it was
daytime outdoor it was just
all the worst things that could happen
in comedy and there was a guy
sitting there with his like daughter
like he was visiting his daughter in
college
and what i said was something crazy like
it was vulgar for sure
especially in the beginning it was all
vulgar [ __ ] and then i saw him look at
me
and they both like the i will remember
this vividly
he him and his daughter look at me and
they look at each other and they're like
and they got up and just left and i was
like
so yeah anyways guys
but i remember them laughing like who
was this dumb [ __ ]
speaking and then got up and left and i
will i always think i
ever not always but every once in a
while in the shower i'll think about him
and i'd cry a little bit
but it's it burned into my [ __ ]
memory it's
oh my god those moments it doesn't
define you but it's it's hard to move
past it just because it's so
traumatizing you could remember
every [ __ ] detail in that moment it's
almost like fighting right it's like
everyone remembers the time that you got
hurt really bad
you got [ __ ] up you just got the [ __ ]
kicked out of you everybody remembers
that vividly it's burned into your
memory
for a good reason to make sure that
never happens again
yeah it definitely makes you not want to
ever do it again yeah 100
just make sure you guys when you do
stand up just don't do it at like these
shitty little open mic things because
there's no crowd for you to play off of
that's the hard part you know if you do
it at a comic club there's a crowd at
least
you know people are there to listen at
least if they have a good drink minimum
but sometimes when you go to these like
because when we started off we just had
to do anything that we can
anything that we could we would do it
and it would be two three people for
their sometimes and you're just doing
these jokes to nobody
yeah right it makes you feel terrible
but it really does i started to realize
how important venues are and how good
promoters are
like oh yeah like people who run that
club if they do a good job they can make
a good show they can make or break you
you know if they choose to do a shitty
show they leave the tvs on they have all
this other [ __ ] they don't do a
drink minimum you're [ __ ] yeah you're
walking into an area that probably only
like the top level people could turn
around
bro we did at a show one time in a bar
and literally it was right after uh a
funeral
like they were like hey we just had a
few times shut the [ __ ] up like dude
they want it it's out of a movie they
want to they want a stand-up show to
like
liven them up hey go
what the [ __ ] also tv's on did you know
that going into this
i i knew that i walked into the place
they're like
you're going up third this is the
situation
someone's wife just died you got 10
minutes
the wife bro that's i was like see if
it's like an old uncle
you just walked on stage it was like i
bet you she's a [ __ ] huh
she was listening i didn't even look the
people in the eyes because like there
was pain in their eyes
i was like trying to talk to him and i
was like i shouldn't be doing who's the
[ __ ] guy that organized this
that that guy should never work in the
business but i was like wow this is
a really bad idea people just started
crying that's when
people are like laughter is the best
medicine like not not after someone just
died no it's not right
right after a funeral absolutely not now
that's just not potent enough dude
it was like a baby there it was awful
dude i've done some cr i've been in
situations where i've been like why who
how did
my life end up in this like why did i do
standards
but that's the true stand-up experience
though i feel like if you don't do that
you do learn from those shitty
experiences though you learn how to like
i mean i don't know what i learned from
that but like
nothing from that one we might have
talked about this on the podcast already
but this guy did a stand-up set
while two people were fighting in this
oh yeah
did we talk about this i think so
in ventura yeah somebody got caught
cheating
and they started fighting and telling
the status of it i think you told me off
podcast
okay i'll just tell you yeah real quick
so i'm on stage okay so
let me uh i'll preface the story by
saying uh
before when i was with jose and willie
on the road i worked with this comedian
named willie barcena who was like
uh he's established and stuff and we
were in sacramento one time and this is
when i was really
my hometown dude uh
what was tommy t's in pleasanton it's
called tommy tees that play sucks we got
him yeah
so we're at tommy t's in pleasanton and
i i mean this is the first time that
like i'm on the road
and [ __ ] and i'm like whoa this is crazy
like i'm doing comedy you know
scott willie's up there and he's telling
his jokes and at some point this dude
starts booing him boo
he's [ __ ] hammered right and then
everyone's like what the [ __ ] like he
did and he
will he's like yo shut the [ __ ] up all
right he tries to keep going but the
guy's hammered boo
bouncer tries to get him out puts his
hands on him the guy pushes the bouncer
bouncer
knocks that guy out boom clean bleep
that guy's friends jump on the bouncer
bouncer's fighting like six dudes the
fans get up
start fighting with the friends it's oh
like a wild west yo
sac town baby like i told you [ __ ]
sacramento weird dude
tackled and at the time i was like i was
like i cuz i was talking to the bouncer
beforehand and i kind of liked him so i
was like about to jump in and jose my
buddy with the black eyes
grabbed me it was hey don't fight like
no don't jump in like
let the [ __ ] go crazy fights
cops end up showing up and then willie
is experienced he's been doing comedy
forever so he like got everybody calmed
down did another 45 minutes
great show it like still went on and i
was like wow 45
after that yeah so he killed it he i
mean he's a he's a headliner he's legit
so fast forward like a couple years or
whatever i'm in ventura
and i'm i'm featuring for jose
was gonna uh uh headline and we're there
and i'm doing my set and honestly it's
not going well it wasn't going well yeah
like it was it was kind of
it was patchy and i was like what the
[ __ ] going on i was like two like
i was just [ __ ] up technically yeah
and um i
feel it and i'm like i'm slipping some
things are hitting some things or not
and then i hear all of a sudden i hear
uh
i hear bear i hear right which is like
spanish for [ __ ] yeah
dog [ __ ] right and i was like what the
[ __ ] i look over
and this dude [ __ ] hits this other
dude what
boom cracks this dude and i'm like what
the [ __ ] like did someone just get
socked
i looked to my right and these two dudes
are squared off right and like i'm
everyone jumps up to like kind of split
it up and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on
and then i see the guy go to choke like
some dude starts choking some woman
right like i didn't know the situation
at the time i didn't know the situation
i just see him and he says better again
and i just see
somebody punch him in the face boom just
crack him and then it's just [ __ ]
chaos like a bra
goes on and everyone's fighting the
comedy show i was just like oh my god
like what the [ __ ]
and like they fight they eventually get
kicked out it takes like [ __ ] two
minutes to kick them out i'm like all
right everybody like sit back down sit
back down sit back down blah blah
and then i just told everybody and i was
like man i'm glad that happened because
i was [ __ ] bombed
and then and then everyone started
laughing and i was like oh sick like
this reenergizer set
and i did my whole set and [ __ ] but i
found out afterwards that that guy
um so what had what had happened was
this guy was sitting and he was sitting
like wearing this like pink shirt and
[ __ ] uh with this lady and
apparently she was cheating on her
husband with this dude in the pink shirt
and cheater the cheater guy
the guy showed up with his his daughter
so his daughter was like in her 20s 30s
it was like an older couple
and he [ __ ] uh he caught them like
together obviously
and he went up to her and uh the
daughter said that's my mom
right or she yelled out that's my mom
that was the first thing that she said
guy punches cheater dude in the head
right boom they're like kind of squared
up
everyone goes to break it up my homie
jose is one of the dudes breaking it up
he turns around grabs his wife yells
starts choking her
and then my buddy jose just saw the guy
he doesn't know the situation but he
just sees this guy
exactly jose cracks this dude boom and
then now him and this dude are [ __ ]
getting down
chaos bro this makes so much sense why
jose had two black guys
but he's down he's done again everyone's
ready to go crackers
dude and uh then then it all got
resolved but i felt bad for like
afterwards i was like damn he got
cheated on and [ __ ] got his ass
whooped in the same night
yeah but like i was able to corral
everybody afterwards and part of it was
because i'd seen it done before yeah
like i was able to sit him down and then
just keep going and it
actually my set went great after that i
was like damn i need to bring
[ __ ] need to fight when i'm
bombing yeah people need to get
down because my [ __ ] got great [ __ ]
tight dude that's so dope
see this is why when i saw those two
guys fighting the street i was like
what's going on guys like they say that
they're saying
he's saying it and that's why i didn't
jump in and he said this guy
stole my [ __ ] wallet and i was like i
did
but sometimes when you're in the heat of
like fighting all that you need is
someone just to like kind of snap you
out of it
because sometimes you're focused you're
like dude i'm gonna murder this fool and
nothing's gonna stop me
yeah until someone like pushes you out
of it and you're like oh [ __ ] like what
am i doing you know
that's all you really need
and then here comes jose sucks his ass i
know holy he's not even involved he's
just like i gotta do this security's bad
at that club huh that guy just walked
yeah it was it wasn't good security but
dude the show usually gets like that
though you just need one good bouncer
you know yeah like what the
[ __ ] does that ever happen how does this
guy just walk in there they had a
bouncer but
he was like like had a toupee and like
oh my god and like with the lamp
there was literally one wooden leg yeah
he's a pirate
[ __ ] yeah you're looking for some
last meme
comedy is crazy but that's like you know
that's what comedy's wild dude
yeah it's it's rarely especially in the
beginning like those good venues like
you're lucky that's what makes you
grateful to be in like the good clubs
the ice house or the improvs
it's like because you've done so many
[ __ ] bars with people yelling and
somebody cheating like if you go to the
ice house
ice house has been some of the best
crowds ever yeah like when i go and when
i've performed there oh like i've only
performed there twice and so but when i
went there it's just like the people who
go to the ice house are looking to laugh
yeah which is what i appreciate right
yeah and if sometimes too like when i've
performed out in new york and like i've
done my own shows
like i'm like this crowd's a little
different i got to make sure i come at
it you know so i gotta
you know write a little bit i can't go
up and just do a [ __ ] set you know
but at icehouse like i've i went up and
didn't prepare a set and you know things
just happened to flow decently well but
sometimes like
wasn't that funny but they still gave me
a chuckle which i appreciate it yeah
because they're ready to laugh
so i've always appreciated ice house
like oh ice house stays forever yeah
yeah i think
it's a great room bro yeah that's my
favorite place i've been watching there
a lot of times yeah it's my favorite
place the main room though especially is
[ __ ] fantastic
yeah it's so dope in there i love it bro
anxiety just thinking about that
i haven't done stand up and since march
yeah how do you feel about that do you
feel [ __ ] nervous what do you have
yeah
i do like to get back into it i'm like
[ __ ] dude like i don't know but it's
it's all scary
it must be kind of nice to think that
like all the other comics are probably
feeling the exact same way
maybe yeah i mean i don't know i've
always had like stage fright though no
of course i feel like everybody does
right even at the highest level right
yeah i got it billboard was talking
about when snl he was like nervous
to go out and it's like crazy to think
that this [ __ ] he did not look
nervous at all
no not even and like the people in the
crowd too were feeling uncomfortable
with his jokes and he still [ __ ]
ripped right through wow i
[ __ ] love bill bird and he's like
damn this guy he's a national that's
like a comic that's what it that's what
a comedian is
yeah that that dude that just says [ __ ]
it [ __ ] you this is what i think
boom one of the worst clips of somebody
bombing was this guy just saying
highly offensive [ __ ] with no humor and
he was mad at the crowd for not finding
it funny
and he was just upset he goes like i
forgot it was it was either
highly misogynistic or racist you like
when you say [ __ ] like that there has to
be a
joke what's the joke like that's what
i'm looking for yeah
and it was bad dude he started yelling
at the crowd for not understanding
comics like no bro you're just not
you're not funny yeah like it has
nothing to do with the crowd they're
perfectly fine they're at the comedy
club
you were not funny yeah that's a common
reaction for a lot of dudes when they're
not doing well is they get pissed at the
crowd
and it's like yeah bro i just started
i'm sorry yeah
yeah i remember one time we saw uh we
saw pat at the comedy store it was like
the uh
it was like one of your earlier shows i
remember i i was in the village
yeah yeah i had a fight the next day and
there was all these communities that
went up
and like there's it's such a weird
feeling when you watch somebody just
bomb on stage and you're in the crowd
because it's like it's not only awkward
for it's obviously awkward for me as the
spectator
but i can only imagine it hurts everyone
everyone there's nobody wins out of this
no one wins nobody wins you just gotta
just this guy went on stage
yeah this guy went on stage and he just
talked about how new york bagels are
worth yeah it was nowhere near as good
as like
la bagels and like his whole thing about
like yeah new york pizza like what's the
deal with it like it's so much better
than la pizza it's like
when people come out here and they say
you know la pizza is so good
he's like i [ __ ] spit on them and
it's like what was worse was that his
whole family was in the front room
i would be like are you writing a yelp
review are you doing a stand-up set you
[ __ ] what are you doing i was like i
was like there's nothing
funny about this dude yeah there is
absolutely nothing
entire family aunts uncles cousins
brothers sisters parents
in the front row and they started
bullying him they were just like they
didn't even laugh like there was
it was silent that's so terrible and he
still continued to do a set
and it's like oh i've had that when i've
invited my friends to come out to my
stand-up set and i completely
bombed and that [ __ ] feels it felt
terrible dude bro it's so bad well i
didn't
it was also it was that time when the
[ __ ] bar with all the tvs and [ __ ] so
it was like the worst situation ever
yeah and i was like that's hard
all your friends are kind of like yeah
man let me buy you a beer i'm like hey
[ __ ] you guys
just give me this beer real quick so i
can get smash and go home and cry myself
to sleep please
[ __ ] man there's so much of that
comedy's so brutal
yeah man and the hardest part too is
like you're well what i suggest anyways
what i do anyways is
you got to look at the crowd you got to
see you're sometimes when you look at
the crowd and you're like oh [ __ ] i
guarantee you these jokes aren't going
to work today
yeah you have to have your backup set to
make sure that it works well like what's
your crowd we're going to be like
and it's been that's probably one of the
hardest things i had to learn because i
would just stick to a set even though
it's not doing well and i'm like
you should be able to just a little bit
on the fly yeah you have to be you know
like if people don't like some of your
crazy jokes you should have someone
that's a little more tame
what are these people like right you
know looking at somebody's ethnicity
age and gender when you go outside
actually helps you mold your
your jokes a little bit better right so
if you're not feeling out the crowd
they're not going to feel your jokes
yeah right
that's why or so good no i'm just going
to say like that's why it's really cool
when you see someone that's really good
at crowd work and they just they just
murder
yeah working just like man no matter
what the set is
if they can always go back to crowd work
you're like man this is fun no matter no
matter who's like
no matter what they're really saying
because it's it's it's just it's so hard
to do that on the fly
oh i would imagine i'm i don't know but
when you watch somebody that's like like
andrew schultz is really good at crowd
work
yeah really frank and he turned in a
moment that's like kind of tense
and just flipping on its head just by
[ __ ] i want to see him live because the
only stuff he puts up is his crowd work
like none of his jokes so
like i haven't heard his jokes yet yeah
like where the [ __ ] is this guy standing
up goddammit well he used to post his
jokes but now it's like mostly like a
long time now you got to say that [ __ ]
that's true that's true
um yeah that would be the thing about
crowd work though too
is that it's because there's like a it's
kind of like you're playing with
dynamite because
people like that it's like oh it's
happening right now in the moment
you know and uh some because i've been
i've done crowd work where i like i said
something i didn't think that was that
funny and people were laughing and
they're like i was like whatever i mean
they're laughing but like whatever
[ __ ] you know because they just seem
clever yeah um but i've seen also which
is kind of weird
i've seen comics that do like prepared
crowd work
they like where it's like it looks like
like hey you're wearing a black shirt
but they have
like a whole thing about like black
shirts but it's not just like
which is fine to like because that's a
technique like especially if you're
dealing with the rowdy room
like if if like uh break a towel you
know you have a joke about black shirts
right
and no one's listening i start making
fun of you because i know you have a
black shirt
boom lead you into this joke that leads
into my set people start listening right
that's i and there's nothing wrong with
that but there's some dudes that like
their whole set
is is crowd work but it's like all
prepared
which is fine you know but it's just
like people could smell it they could
sniff it out
yeah some guys are really good at making
it seem like it's not because i but i've
seen it and i've been like
it just seems kind of sad to me because
it's like damn doesn't it get old like
yeah eric spears too he does like crowd
work too that's kind of set up but
this will did this joke that cracked me
the [ __ ] up because you're looking at
his asian girl
and he was like are you he's like
sweetie where are you right she goes she
goes i'm chinese he's like
[ __ ] the worst joke was about when you
visited me so you've been to me anyways
that's hilarious i remember i went to
one of your shows
it was in gl it was in burbank what's
the place in burbank clappers it was a
yeah it was flappers yeah and the whole
time it was like a smaller room
but i was sitting in the middle in the
back and i think i'm sitting with khaled
or something like that and the whole
time like i guess
this one comic just kept talking about i
have a small
obviously small dick asian joke full
time and i just was like bro like [ __ ] i
can't get your goddamn break
and then every comedian afterwards that
went up just kept
pointing me out over and over again
small decades and jokes and then next
comic
small dick asian joke and i just was
like all right guys it's getting really
old
i want to see my friend patrick he came
up it was like small dick asian jokes
i was like pat i'll be your friend dude
yeah but
you know it's
that'd be hilarious if you had like the
biggest dong ever and you just whipped
it out they're like
all right leave the club you're arrested
yeah you know you get arrested
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
that was a fantastic episode if i do my
seison myself
you sound like me dude
well you can catch patrick.t.riley on
instagrams and everything
the like and then you have nick the ear
you can see him at nick the ear on the
instagrams as well for that
personal training advice also the best
back anus massages i've ever had in my
life yeah baby i make the best sweet tea
as well
we'll see y'all next time peace